nous allons étudier attentivement
l'ensemble des 97 recommandations qui
ont été faites tant sur la question des
télécommunications de la radiodiffusion
et du contenu en ligne monsieur le
président notre gouvernement est
déterminé à soutenir ce secteur au
canada
monique simard et membre du groupe
d'examen du cadre législatif en matière
de radiodiffusion et de
télécommunication bonsoir madame simone
long et c'est un gros rapport
c'était une base du réseau d un vaste
chantier vous arrivez à 97
recommandation c'est une réforme
complète du monde des télécommunications
c'est ça et et des communications c'est
vrai pour les communications et on avait
30 est une question dont 97
recommandations pour répondre à 30 est
une question et je pense que ce rapport
c'est très important de le prendre dans
son ensemble il ya en tout il ya une
logique qui traversent ce rapport basé
sur un certain nombre de valeurs
importantes qui sont la souveraineté
culturelle du pays
l'équité des bals des valeurs décotées
et des démocraties et ensuite on est
rentré dans chacune des délais sous
section du rapport est le point de
départ de tout cela c'est l'enjeu
netflix à un certain moment de
gouvernement du canada a annoncé que
netflix investissent et au canada des
gens se sont dit d'écouter netflix
devrait payer ses impôts en tout cas
aller chercher les taxes la dps
notamment le faire de façon normale vous
vous proposez vous êtes d'avis dans vos
propositions qu'on devrait s'assurer
qu'une entreprise comme netflix investit
alors on sait qu'il ya eu des débats il
ya deux ans parler de la fameuse 4e sans
jamais existé ça en fait à l'époque
c'était effectivement la question de la
taxe de vente la tps et tvq
d'ailleurs le québec et la saskatchewan
l'ont perçu depuis deux ans et ils se
sont conformés il n'y a pas que netflix
s'est conformé c'est toutes les
plateformes étrangères et vous pensez
que netflix de que le gouvernement du
canada devrait le faire alors si tu me
lis une des mesures qu'on propose
immédiate
ok c'est que yagg l'ict et au niveau des
taxes de bars ont fait des affaires dans
ce pays
eh bien on doit incapable de percevoir
des taxes comme ses visées
beacon canadien ça c'est une chose
l'autre chose qui est peut-être la plus
importante c'est si on fait des affaires
justement qu'on retire des revenus
publicitaires ou des revenus
d'abonnement au canada et bien il faut
réinvestir contribuer à la politique
culturelle canadienne alors on a des
systèmes de promesses d'investissements
dans la production et de la
découvrabilité et quand je dis
production pas de la production de
services où on vient faire une série
américaine qui ont fait travailler des
équipes techniques bon ça c'est une
chose c'est bien mais vraiment
d'investir dans la production de contenu
canadien
netflix ne fait pas déjà non mais un ou
deux presque pas et comme n'y a pas eu
de transparence par rapport à leurs
chiffres c'est très difficile à savoir
et on peut on peut les pousser à faire
c'est oui on peut les pousser écouter on
peut tout faire dans un pays c'est à
dire que on a édicté des règles
une chose qui est importante c'est que
l'univers médiatique c'est tellement et
quand je dis médiatique c'est tellement
ça inclut les journaux aussi avec la
presse écrite s'est même transformée en
tellement été perturbé ça a été un peu
la récréation pendant 20 ans et l'osi
s'est terminée la récréation il faut se
conformer à un certain nombre de règles
il faut suivre certain nombre de
consignes parce que notre avenir
culturel en d'état alors pourquoi pas
une taxe sur les profits comme la france
est en train de faire en ce moment ça
c'est ce qui est discuté à la halle au
cdi alors nous on dit ça c'est pas que
le domaine du culturel ni seulement du
domaine des télécommunications amazon
par exemple perturbe un secteur le
secteur du top commerce au détail donc
ça c'est un autre niveau
et là il ya des discussions qui disent
bon il faudrait qu'on a qu'on applique
un pourcentage d'impôts mais ça c'est
pas dans votre rapport nous c'est non
une fois dans votre mission dépend d'un
autre ça n'était pas dans notre mandat
rejet une autre question les
fournisseurs de contenus internet comme
les vidéotron les belles notamment est
ce que eux ils pourraient pas contribuer
au financement du contenu canadien
ces deux choses différentes par exemple
des autres ont ils débattront entre
fournisseurs d'accès internet et vous
donne pas du contenu yves donne une
connexion ont dit oui
ils devront contribuer comme nos autres
fournisseurs d'accès internet contribue
à établir le système de connectivité
dans le pays parce que vous savez on
déclare dans notre rapport va être bien
connecté c'est un droit aujourd'hui on
peut pas exercer sa citoyenneté on peut
pas dans l'économie sont nos postes donc
ils vont contribuer là ce qu'ils nous
proposent du contenu alors netflix par
exemple ses pattes et failli créer un
oui mais bon eux auront des obligations
d'investissement dans la production
canadienne et dans la découvrabilité ça
c'est important
encore faut-il avoir un produit si les
gens savent pas qu'il existe et on a
aussi d'autres points formule aussi de
redevances les cinq ans on était entre
du monde ont encore estime traditionnels
puis on rentre dans un nouveau monde
donc on va maintenir en un certain
talent période de transition de mesures
transitoires jeu montré un graphique qui
tirait de votre rapport sur la publicité
les revenus de publicité dans le monde
des médias
chut ça c'est très clair et pour
l'internet regardez c'est la ligue sedan
bat barreaux
les revenus de publicité s'en vont sur
internet la ligne télé c'est la ligne
bleue c'est celle qui baissent le moins
la came avait un petit peu mais pourquoi
vous aller jusqu'à dire que radio canada
et cbc ne devrait plus du tout retirer
de revenus publicité alors notre
opposition elle est en deux volets et
c'est une proposition pour radio-canada
d'ailleurs on réaffirme sans hésitation
la nécessité d'un média public fort et
on dit d'abord ce média devrait être
financée et mieux financées par des
crédits parlementaires comme si la
majorité des gérants
mais pour dix crus mais pour une période
de cinq ans donc un engagement sur un
budget pendant cinq à ce qu'on dit
progressivement devra se désengager des
revenus publicitaires sur cinq ans parce
que de toute façon vous avez indiqué
lacombe buzz
mais ça c'est toutes les télés on voit
que radio canada chaque année à un petit
peu moins d'argent publicité à on dit si
on pense vers l'avenir
on peut résumer quand on aura encore
moins donc on dit mais il faut que ses
revenus soient remplacés par des crédits
parlementaires
10 ionel de l'argent public est stable
sur une plus longue période
parce que l'instabilité financière et la
pire affaire quand on est un médian et
quand on voit des revenus qui sont
disparus sur facebook entre autres les
plateformes la crise des médias écrits
c'est entre autres ça c'est que les
modèles d'affaires qui ont été fondés
sur les revenus publicitaires sont en
train de disparaître
mais on danse que notre proposition on
va aller lui chercher aussi des
contributions et des redevances sur les
plateformes de partage notre émission
est terminée je vous rêvez très pour
parler de la réforme du crtc
monique simard merci beaucoup on a
plaisir